those beliefs are out there and then you
have the debate of good aliens versus
bad aliens are they here to save us from
destroying the planet and destroying
ourselves with nuclear weapons and so on
or are they here to kill us all that
debate is rampant out there uh that
brings up a whole new aspect to this
conversation which I'm fascinated by but
to sum it up why would they care because
if they are there and we are here and
they can get here the likelihood of us
being the only two life forms in the
cosmos is nil so why would they care
it's to me I attribute it to the antel
analogy do we care that there's an anel
in the middle of the Sahara Desert
that's about to go to war with another
Colony or a termite hill whatever do we
go out there and plant our US flag and
go we will save you we're hiring we've
got bigger weapons uh we're much more
intelligent than you we probably can't
talk but we will save you I'm sorry the
intelligence gap between us and an ant
is likely closer than us and a a
civilization that started 2 million
years ago I believe that because I think
that their intelligence will be so far
surpassed our own why would they want to
come here and number one even talk to us
but number two save us does it matter
you know the only reason they would is
if we are the only two uh in the cosmos
you know if there's just a handful of
civilizations in this vast Universe to
me that's not even likely but you know
that's the only reason they would and if
that is the case how would we ever find
each other right so so there's a lot of
questions that I think we have to to
ponder here it's not about was that UFO
an alien spaceship going across the
Pacific Ocean uh but rather we have to
really drill deep into a lot of these
pressing questions that you have to
tackle if you want to believe in
extraterrestrials or here see for the
antill analogy I don't think people
think about it carefully enough because
if the ants were able to communicate to
us there would be teams of scientists
there would be new stories about look we
can now communicate with ants further
virtually every single species on the
planet has a professor whose sole job it
is to study it it's difficult to find a
life form that we're not interested in
and then third we are concerned with
species
preservation so if the ants were going
to war with gorillas and one of them
were going to be wiped out somehow we
would care about that like we already
care about that and there are some
people who care about Extinction so
there's both sides so I don't see this
dispassionate assessment because it's an
antill and we're so much more advanced
as holding up to indicate that we don't
want to intervene or communicate back
because if we could that would be
firstly we're teaching gorillas to try
and communicate to them same with
parrots and we're super excited when
they can say a syllable or string
together a verb and an adjective and
it's like a revolutionary chsky gets
involved yeah you you bring up a great
you bring up a great rebuttal the only
reason I would I would push back is not
every human being studies you're talking
about a very small percentage of humans
that that make that study and that care
um I'm one of those that care right so I
I'm an animal geek I love that I love
that kind of stuff but sadly Humanity
doesn't so the reason I bring up the
analogy is talking about life forms as a
whole uh here on Earth uh Humanity as a
whole what's the percentage that cares
broaden that to a wider scope in the
universe uh to find a full civilization
that would again want to come here and
speak to us and and save us um that to
me is more of the point that it would be
a much smaller if if a percentage point
at all but on top of all that using what
uh rebuttal you just brought up which
was great um we want to save that life
form because all we know is one planet
and that's it right so so life is
precious to us as it I and I agree with
that right like I believe life is
precious but if if then the universe and
Cosmos is teeming with life would
another Advanced civilization have that
same appreciation and that same care to
go okay people of Earth or creatures of
Earth uh you know we we don't want you
to be extinct we want to we want to
coddle you I want to believe that that's
true because I'm the type that in my
backyard I will save a hummingbird in my
pool which there's pictures I we do that
all the time me and my kids we'll save
hummingbirds we'll save so we do that
right but it's because we have that
appreciation for life would a
civilization millions of years ahead of
us in a cosmos teaming with life care
and and that's that's I think the bigger
question here is that we want to think
they would because of humanity and where
we are in the infant stages that we are
but the reality is it could be a machine
that we run into when we talk about an
extraterrestrial and and that brings up
this whole other debate uh wherein we we
are operating off the assumption that we
are going to run in to a biological
creature of some kind but that
unanswered question is when that happens
if it hasn't already will it be
biological at all and then that brings
up a whole other slew of questions
so I get your your point absolutely but
for me I remove myself as much as I can
from humanity and try and look at it as
a bigger picture and that's where I feel
the the ant analogy then comes into play
yeah I see that I'll say some thoughts
that occur to me number one is that if
they're sufficiently Advanced then they
would have something like Auto GPT so
right now we have AIS and they can run
automatically without our intervention
so it could be that even though the
average person doesn't care about a
particular animal like you mentioned
there's a subset of people who care
about a particular animal even though
that's the case it could just be it runs
automatically so it doesn't matter that
all of us as a whole aren't it could be
that you're sending out probes
automatically secondly this is something
I think about we tend to think that
what's valuable is what's rare so like
diamonds and gold but it may be the case
that we have that backward and that
that's based in something like
materialism and that what may be the
most valuable is what's the most
abundant and that is to say like our
Consciousness or our meaning or
significance it's a difficult concept to
parse out because we tend to make an
equivalence between what's valuable and
what's rare and what's uncommon I don't
see it as being completely obvious that
what's precious is what's most rare it
may be the opposite what's precious is
what's most
common yeah and you bring up an
interesting I'm not sure if this will
connect to your thought at all but you
bring up an interesting point about the
gold and and the you know the precious
metals that are precious to us and and
and therefore
valuable if we were able to go out those
precious
to us humans is completely abundant like
there's that one I forget exactly the
value of the the comet that they said is
is worth like quintili of dollars uh and
that you know the idea is that if you go
out and actually can rope it and bring
it in and you can start mining it and
and so on and so forth it brings up I
guess an interesting concept that what
and which kind of plays into my point
earlier is that what is essentially rare
to us that we we value it more gold is
much more valuable than dirt you know
because it's it's much it's much more
precious to us and so on and so forth
and and therefore we coddle that and we
we we we hold on to it it's got value it
grows in value but using gold as the
example in the cosmos that's one of
those precious metals that if you rope
one of those comets you completely crash
the gold market here uh because you you
are just overflowing with it and it's
not precious anymore it's just a metal
it's just dirt you know it's not worth
anything uh that I think plays into what
I was saying earlier where here on Earth
Humanity values what it does cuz we're
small and that's all we know but once
that broadens to literally a cosmic
scale those values change both monetary
values but also what's here and what's
here in our mind and our heart so it it
it it's a
mindblowing topic because you can go so
so many different ways and like you said
does the abundance create value I'm not
sure maybe maybe with a higher
intelligence that would come into play
but sadly for Humanity as you and I chat
right now that's not that's not the case
and and that's that's how we have to at
this point think about how it might be
out there just CU we don't know where
we're going to be in a thousand years if
you enjoyed that clip then the full
podcast is out right now you can click
around here enjoy subscribe to theories
of everything to get notified of
upcoming podcasts as there are new full
length podcasts every week on the topics
of mathematics physics Consciousness
Free Will and
AI